the Libyan capital is ringed with
defensive barriers this is a city under
siege many here fought in the revolution
which toppled their former dictator
Colonel Gaddafi and they blamed the West
for the mess they're in now they must
end it you know when they started in
2011 they must and now different
fighting units once at odds aligned up
together to defend Tripoli against the
forces commanded by a former Gaddafi
general Khalifa Hefner and the battles
are amongst homes and businesses
[Music]
thousands of families have been forced
to flee their homes
to get out of the line of fire with city
frontlines constantly shifting there's a
real fear about what's going to happen
here
and nothing seems to be off limits this
was a junior school the area where
pupils gathered for their morning
assembly there appears to be no military
target nearby and it's attacks like
these which the International Criminal
Court is investigating for potential war
crimes with claims that there are abuses
on both sides these are some of those
captured and accused of working for
Khalifa Hefner who's formed his own army
and set up a rival administration in the
east of Libya but is now bent on taking
control of the capital there are more
than a hundred of them and they say they
were recruited just a few months ago
lured by money
some of them say they're under 18 we
asked them to step forward the Tripoli
government claims the advancing forces
have recruited children and they're keen
to show us some of them with their
guards watching they tell us they were
duped into joining the Hefner forces
miss banana son Naveen it wasn't what we
thought it was it wasn't what we were
told was going to happen they say they
thought they were going on parade when
they were seized on the outskirts of
Zuria 50 kilometers from the capital
basically it was all about the money
it's difficult here while the fighting
groups battle it out many civilians are
moving several times Rwanda is uprooted
her young family twice already in less
than a fortnight does this feel like
civil war to you Libyans against Libyans
I hope it's not she says everyone's
trying to liberate their area and each
side thinks they're right I'm not sure
who is right and who is wrong many of
the displaced are relying on donations
but are angry about being put in this
position in the first place they're
furious at the West's involvement during
the Arab revolution and the lack of a
post-war plan where do we go tell me
where do we go let the whole world see
is this freedom is this democracy like
that destruction you want to rule the
country have elections don't go
destroying houses who do you blame
[Music]
where's the international community
where's the international community who
led Libya to this point and let us down
where is the United Nations
they're not even issuing a resolution to
protect civilians where is the
international community where are they
they feel abandoned and now vulnerable
but the UN recognized government here
insists they will fight to defend the
capital with or without outside help
Alex Crawford Sky News Tripoli